the division remission is a comic that
was released back in 2019 but was only
available in french it has since been
released in english as of december 2021
in this video i'll be covering the story
from a narrative point of view this is a
little different to how the story is
told from the character's viewpoint but
i've done my best with maintaining the
overall direction
however for the full experience i would
definitely recommend getting the comic
either online or hardcopy as this will
provide a better idea of the story
showing a full extent of the characters
involved
otherwise this is your last warning if
you haven't read the comic yet and
you're intending to this video will
contain spoilers
[Music]
[Music]
while clearing out a group of hyenas who
are guarding a facility the cell leader
bruce receives a message on his beeper
help captured by hyenas at the lincoln
statue come quick
the beeper isn't a standard piece of shd
equipment this was just something bruce
has had since he was a kid and given the
current situation where 4g and computer
networks are down beepers come out on
top they communicate via radio signals
plus they can't be hacked
the message he received was from a close
friend of his called mike
so he quickly gathers together five
other agents and they make their way to
the location of the statue
when they arrive at the location given
to him by his friend they find a large
group of hyenas concentrated in one area
one of them presumably the group's
leader is preaching about their cause
while the rest of them cheer him on
bruce and the other agents then watch on
as a group of people are herded towards
the statue at gunpoint the hyenas leader
then commands them to climb up
it was at that moment that mike received
a message from bruce
telling him and the other hostages to
take cover
a single shot is fired it pierces the
canister on the back of one of the
hyenas
there is a small explosion and before
the rest of them can react the division
agents are upon them and demanding they
drop their weapons or they will open
fire
predictably the hyenas raise their
weapons
although they vastly outnumbered the
agents they were no match for them
the gunfire could be heard across the
district
mike received a message from another
friend he alluded of his capture john
he told him he was fine and that the
division had saved him
bruce and the other agents gathered the
hostages and told them that they would
escort them to a safe house the theater
on their way mike and john continue to
message each other
john who was close by to the fight with
the hyenas had spotted bruce and was
surprised to learn that he was a
division agent
he hadn't seen him in over a year and
well before the pandemic
mike and john had kept in close contact
with each other over the years since the
disappearance of janus another childhood
friend
before they reached the settlement mike
sent one more request to john he asked
if he could go to his house and see if
his wife and child were okay
they could be located in his panic room
now safe in the settlement mike and
bruce finally had a chance to catch up
mike explains that jon is going to get
his family to safety bruce admits that
he hasn't seen him in a long time but
that he was never too worried about him
he always seemed to know how to look
after himself
mike's talents were recognized for a
very young age and he was even the one
who managed to hook up the power to the
childhood tree house
mike john bruce and janice would spend
all of their spare time there
this is when janus first borrowed or
stole brother a bunch of beepers from a
local electronic store
after mike configured them the four of
them would use these to communicate and
keep track of each other
just then the sound of the police siren
pierced the air and it was rapidly
getting closer
consequently it stopped outside of the
treehouse
janus had been residing there with a
younger brother and now their father
wanted his son to come home
their dad was an abusive drunk the
neighbours knew it the kids knew it the
police knew it and yet he was still
granted full custody thanks to his
friend who was a judge on the case
janna slipped down from the treehouse
screaming that she would never let him
hurt them again
then without warning she pulled a knife
on her father threatening to slash him
and the police automatically drew the
weapons the boys quickly descended the
treehouse ladder bringing her brother
with them
mike spoke to her promising they would
check in and give a close eye on her dad
but right now she needed to drop the
knife
upset janice conceded
the police then guided her brother into
the car
and then left taking him and her father
home
jon made it to mike's neighborhood
mike had done well for himself through
his career in computer science so this
was quite a nice area before the
outbreak
while making his way into the building
he could hear a noise coming from
downstairs in the wine cellar
in front of him were five hyena members
attempting to pry open one of the panels
john introduced himself telling them to
step aside saying that he was a hyena
too and is a good friend of one of the
council members
the hyenas told him to get lost
undeterred john raises his weapon and
after a short burst of gunfire their
bodies littered the ground
he then shouted out to mike's wife
saying that he was here to help take
them somewhere safe
recognizing jon they opened the door
they packed up some things including
mike's old backpack
but as they were leaving the cellar one
of the hyenas raised their arm and fired
in their direction
jon quickly turns and guns them down
none of them were hit but the bullet had
pierced through mike's bag
john stopped to check that everything
inside was okay when he suddenly
discovered something that shocked him
when janice disappeared all she said to
the guys was that she had no choice but
she needed to go away
mike said that he saw police outside her
house while he was on his way to the
treehouse
inside they turn on the tv to see if it
mentions anything about it on the news
the reporter on the tv announces that
two bodies have been found janice's
father had been stabbed to death but
before this he had murdered his son
janice was a prime suspect as she had
been caught threatening her father in
front of police officers
but she had escaped using her father's
car
bruce john and mike grew up together
they were big comic book fans but felt
they never fit in with the other kids so
they decided to go out and build a tree
house so they would have somewhere quiet
to read their comics
they got to work but quickly realized
that this was a little over their head
one day janice showed up saying that
she'd been watching their progress over
the last few days the boys knew of
janice she had a reputation around
school and someone you really didn't
want to cross
she offered to help explaining that she
had built a couple of treehouses in the
past
she had also brought along a number of
materials that she had stolen from the
local hardware store
and three years later they were chilling
in their tree house
janice took care of everything and by
this stage they were an inseparable
group of friends
after janice's disappearance everything
changed
the boys stopped seeing each other so
much and started drifting apart
but they agreed to meet up once a year
at the treehouse on the day of her
disappearance to remember her
mike would get deep into his studies
attending prestigious universities
eventually creating a company that made
it big in apps
john isolated himself becoming obsessed
with survival
and bruce focused on sport before
eventually being contacted by the
division
john makes his way to the hyena camp
at the gate he gives the password and
his identification
after only making it in a few steps he
is jumped by a group of hyena members
he was brought in front of the council
member who proceeded to question him on
why he attacked and killed his fellow
hyena allies
jon goes on to explain that the men and
the seller were going to ruin his big
plan
that he has a way of acquiring enough
materials supplies and weapons to have
them live like kings
john continues by telling the council
member how he had gained the trust of an
individual inside the theater settlement
and after securing his wife and child he
had them locked away so the husband
would do anything he commanded of him
john spent the next several days working
on his plan
using the information being feedback
from mike he was able to learn the
layout the number of guards the patrol
routines how they react to attacks in
the areas around them and where the
supplies are being stored
on sunday night bruce receives a message
on his bieber from janus
he has a lot of ground to cover in a
short period of time so he rushes to get
ready and runs out the door leaving the
camp behind him
out of breath having run the hallway
there he climbs the treehouse
when suddenly he takes a blow to the
side of his head knocking him out cold
bruce wakes several hours later he is
still in the treehouse but his hands are
bound he calls out for janus but no one
is there
cutting himself free he makes his way
out of the treehouse
once on the ground he sees the smoke in
the distance
coming from the theater's settlement
when he arrives back at camp the damage
is extensive
one of the guards explained that they
managed to get in when the guard changed
they ran through the compound like they
owned the place
they knew their way around
they must have had someone on the inside
bruce found one of his fellow agents and
he explained what happened
that the first rocket was fired on the
division agents who were on the rooftop
at the time
bruce's heart sank
katie one of the agents was someone he
was having a relationship with the only
positive thing he'd had in his life
since the pandemic began
he found her in the hospital bandaged
from head to toe
she didn't look like she had much time
she managed to utter a few words to
bruce about how after the explosion she
saw mike talking to one of the hyenas
whose name was john
katie's speech was cut off mid-sentence
as her body began seizuring
the medical staff rushed in pushing him
out of the room
rather than watching through the window
he returned to his room taking her
positions with him when something
suddenly dropped from the bag and landed
between his feet
it was a pregnancy test and it was
positive
bruce spent the remainder of the day in
his room grieving and destroying
everything in sight
by night time he had finally decided to
emerge
he hands his room keys over and tells
him that he's leaving the settlement
that he has always fought for justice
but now that time is over and the only
thing left is
revenge
bruce enters mike's house and discovers
the panic room and a number of dead
hyenas outside
if jon is a hyena why would he be
killing other hyenas
maybe jon has his wife and daughter held
hostage
before leaving he grabs his id and
passport and hopes that these might help
him find mike
with help from odysseus sawyer bruce
manages to locate some family members of
john's at a refugee camp
they tell him about someone called jaw
john used to hang out with him before
the pandemic that he would get him into
a bit of trouble and that they joined
the hyenas together
odyssa is aware of jaw she explains that
he controls all of the southeast suburbs
bruce intends to attack the main camp
alone a suicide mission that he just
doesn't want to get anyone else hurt
odyssa talks him around saying that she
has been in contact with the other
agents he was traveling with up until
recently
mike has been strapped down to a bed
john is leaning over the bed
interrogating him on why he found
janice's beeper and knife in his bag all
these years later
mike started his story from the
beginning
he and janice were in a relationship but
had chosen to keep it a secret
whenever they weren't at the tree house
they were at a father's house to keep an
eye out for a younger brother and try to
protect him
one night they heard screams coming from
the house and the russian side to find
her little brother lying on the ground
with blood around his head and an empty
bottle
janus ran over to his still and lifeless
body and soon after pulled out her knife
yet just as quickly she was kicked to
the ground by her father
the knife landed at mike's feet he
picked it up and rushed towards the man
forcefully driving the knife through his
chest while janice's father desperately
tried to kick back mike continued to
stab him over and over again
janice attempted to pull her father off
mike but in the altercation she too
ended up being struck in the chest
had killed both of them
the division launched a full attack on
the hyena compound
taken by surprise the hyenas didn't
stand a chance
when things appeared to be in their
favor bruce broke off from the group in
search of mike and john
eventually he found jon on the third
floor of a private clinic
bruce called out demanding john stand
down right away
however it was at this time that he
noticed the blood-covered knife in his
hand and realized there was a body on
the table
john claimed that mike told him to do it
when the explosions outside started
going off he didn't want to live with
everything he'd done on his conscience
john reached into his vest pocket
bruce screamed at him to stop moving but
he didn't and then fired three rounds to
his chest
he was only reaching for janice's bieber
but it was too late
bruce asked why he had a beeper and
knife
bleeding out in front of him john
explained that all he wanted to do was
help mike and understand why he had
genesis things
but he was in the settlement and he
wouldn't be able to get in so he lied to
the council in order to get them to raid
it so he could get mike out
this is why bruce received the message
from genesis beeper
john was trying to keep him away from
the attack
jon filled him in on what mike had said
about the night that she went missing
how he had accidentally killed her and
that he took her body away using her
dad's car and buried her under the tree
house
with his dying breaths john asked if he
too could be buried next to her
bruce took both mikes and john's bodies
and buried them next janus
he was now the sole survivor of this
long lost group of friends however at
least now he had some closure of what
had happened to janus
he took a moment to reflect back on
their time together in the past
but he knew his job was far from done
so when he was ready he collected his
things and marched towards the city as
at this point of time his assistance was
needed more now than ever
i quite enjoyed the story but i'm not
gonna lie i don't think it was a great
division story the division element
could have been replaced with a number
of other things and it wouldn't have
changed much
i enjoy the other multimedia editions
because they go into a little more
detail on the division universe or
expand on it offering a little more to
the world in everything that's happening
this was more just a story of a group of
friends and how an incident pulled them
apart and then eventually brought them
back together later on
like i said a good story but just not
what i was after as an addition to the
universe
while i have you guys especially ones
that have made it as far through the
video i've been accused a number of
times of trying to seduce you through
the way that i talk
while this is certainly not the
intention i have one question
did it work
perhaps i should be looking into some
sort of asmr content though i'm sure my
wife wouldn't approve
we do what we can to feed the family
right
anyway i hope you found the story
entertaining and i'll catch you in the
next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]